In the quest to be clever,...
...I completely forgot about the people that I love and the people that love me.
And I went,...
...as I had begun to do into a wormhole of selfishness...
...and greediness and arrogance, in thinking that if I just continue to be...
...speedy and witty and pull together as many fast words and phrases that I could,...
...that I could be clever enough to buy myself another day,...
...without thinking that anybody would find me, pin me down, and say, "You're a creep!"
And when I should have just given that up and played the guitar a little bit more,...
...I didn't. So I decided that I would try to be as clever as possible all the time.
And I did that at the expense of people that I love.
And that feels absolutely terrible.
It feels worse than any headline I thought I could get my way out of.
I think it's important that you know that everybody on the stage...
...is here playing with me not because they condone...
...what I say in any given interview and certainly not in the interview that's made the rounds today.
They're not on the stage because they support what I said.
They're on the stage because they support myself as a possible future grown up.